um
oh
keep by the cells
is
easy
easy
oh
uh
fuji
uh
love it
oh
wow
so
um
you oh
so
so
foreign
she finally made me realize
subject for today
oh there it is got a good slur you got
it oh
and i do it because it's a it's a
palette cleanser for the uh
for the uh the coffee i like it's also
delicious
not a big fan of the coffee breath uh i
had a bad morning this morning because i
i mistimed the shower you ever do that
where you you're you're sweating you're
either working out or you're in a hot
car or you leave your dog in a hot car
and then you get into the shower but you
get out of the shower
i don't have dog mode i don't know tesla
that's true well what am i going to do
take him into tom thumb
he can stand the heat um and so then i
got out and i was still sweaty and so
now my hair looks like willard
uh we have ann dorn on the show today
mrs
officer david dorn i'm gonna be talking
about kamala harris we're going to be
talking about uh
a whole lot of things folks uh my half
asian lawyer bill richmond is here how
are you
reg the bandit our wonderful researcher
here he scares me good to be here
how are you sir and audio wade is there
and uh token allen but he's not talking
to us so please do subscribe on the
crowder bits on youtube
uh hit the notification bell and um
apple podcast
android we're available wherever you
want to list on audio of course we go to
web extended for those who are members
of mug club
after we tell youtube to piss off and
then
then you get more content and that'll be
with uh mrs david dorn something else
too
next week we'll be live streaming uh
wednesday and thursday night the dnc
there uh we were gonna do it every night
of the week but that would be three or
four hours
and you would just see an actual news
not like a fake nascar news
yeah but you would just garage pool like
you just see my legs hanging
and also gasoline dripping with a lit
match for safety because it wouldn't be
one of those cries for help
it would be end me nobody wants that no
nobody wants well you know
i could question let me ask you this is
obviously what everyone is talking about
kamala harris
joe biden's vp choice do you think it
helps
or hurts joe biden's chances and then as
far as it relates to kamala harris
of all of her sins what do you think is
the most degree just let us know i want
to know your opinions and you know what
the comment section has been
become pretty good after the change of
mind yeah a lot of discussions are
around
uh what are you saying a bad morning now
there i had a bad morning yeah what
happened
well my mom saw the news about kamala oh
really
and she was like not not a doctor you
went to a public school
and you weren't even the first half
asian to make it
presidency or vice president i mean hey
you know what she's south asian she is
half asian
yeah uh i'd say giving a bad name to
half asians but uh we'll see how it
bears out
you know it's funny but when you think
harris you don't think half asian yeah
that's true but neither do i with
richmond yeah i was going to say
you know richmond is that just bringing
i had no idea
until i first met you i was like oh okay
and i know looking back i know that he
knew what was going on he's like
what's that i'm like i don't know bill
william really leaning on all the time
all the time okay well first we actually
have to we have a lot of sponsors uh we
have to go to our sponsor before we talk
about kamala harris
uh i believe today um we have a special
sponsor thank you very much to toast
tired of spreading butter on a regular
piece of normal colored bread
sick of sopping up your plate of eggs
with a second plate of eggs
well now you don't have to with toast
toast is similar to bread but worlds
apart
because toast is the result of your
bread being heated in a device
after which it emerges slightly darker
you can then use the toast as a side
accompaniment or a meal all its own
enjoying its subtle
but noticeably crunchier flavor that
satisfies even plain bread's greatest
critics
go to toast.toast and enter promo code
toast for seven percent off your first
order that's toast.toast
promo code toast if you order in the
next 10 minutes we'll include a discount
on the lottery with crowder proprietary
browning bread box to help make your own
toast at home
that's toast.toastpromo code toast to
try it for yourself today
i don't want that sponsor anymore oh i'm
glad to have them on well i think it's
what i particularly don't like is the
hipster with his id card
he really is like a six toast spring
yeah you know what's always bothering me
about toast
what if you leave toast out it turns
back into squishy bread it does
but if you but if you leave bread out it
turns into toast it gets hard yeah but
that's for the birds ladies and
gentlemen
uh you just let it stale apparently
birds like stealing do you think birds
all this time
have been preferring moist bread and
they get stale bread
and every time show they don't even know
what the hell we should have a bird on
to talk about that dog in the car you
give me the stale bread
we can't we don't have the digestive
tract for biscotti uh
we're gonna go to come on but first
before we talk about kamala harris of
course the man who picked kamala harris
former vice president that's a scary
phrase joseph biden
uh this week in biden go you know you
know the thing
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talented white kids wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black
okay so this is the guy who picked the
half asian lady uh as his vice
presidential candidate and i don't know
if you notice when i tune in
half asian bill looks very cross let's
give him a bill
let's see what's is that sanjay gupta
look at him he has the uh the early 90s
hockey cut yeah look at that
i was gonna say he is hockey yeah he has
the marty mcstorey he has the enforcer
for
for los angeles king's wayne gretzky
haircut and you know that's a virtue
signaling haircut
because he won't go get his hair cut
right yeah social distancing
like come on he could get he could get
his dame to grab a pair of clippers and
i recommend you do
gupta but instead he said you know what
i'm going to let everyone the whole
world will see
my neck hair mullet and it's not even a
good mullet it's just a lazy
mullet and you're a doctor it's an
overcomer you're a doctor sanjay gupta
it's probably unhygienic it is growing
in that thing
i don't know if he's i assume he's not
actually practicing as most of these
doctors on cnn so he's probably avoided
most of the microbes but a doctor should
have his hair
sure and if they have to do it at shake
shack they have to wear a hair net
i'm not having that guy perform an
operation on me i wouldn't trust him all
right let's see what they're talking
about let's see
mandate hand hygiene kids back to school
create the physical distancing as much
as possible which is probably the
biggest challenges
biggest challenge they've even gone
through the process of getting kids and
faculty tested the real problem you know
about the real problem where we live at
this point we live in an area
where there is considerable viral spread
as i've looked at the data from around
the world in terms of how kids transmit
the virus i've become increasingly
convinced
that kids really of any age can spread
this virus okay
that's enough this is the problem that
they're talking about notice they focus
now on
kids can spread the virus well yeah
initially they talked about a crazy
death rate and we said well actually
it's probably a lot lower because a lot
of people are asymptomatic more people
have the virus and we realize and now
they're going oh i got more people who
kids get
more people have the virus that we
realize but if
kid a spreads it to kid b
and neither one of them have any
symptoms or a problem and in the state i
believe was it in new york donald trump
spoke about this
only one person under the age of 18 died
and they had diabetes
if none of them or very few of them have
ill effects that is something that you
take into consideration when
shutting down the economy for their
entire generation to come
no one's saying that kids can't get it
we're saying that kids
by and large and i know this could be
removed from facebook and twitter like
the present
most of the time virtually almost all
are asymptomatic and they're fine now if
you want to say that those kids
shouldn't come home because they might
give mr mullet doctor
uh the virus himself and it could then
fine fine just say it's about you it's
not about the kids it's about you
this is about you you don't want to send
your kids to school because you don't
want the sniffles
dr sanjay gupta you want to continue on
down the mullet trail so you can show
everyone
how good of a non-practicing doctor you
are looking at the data
by the way was the same guy who looked
at the data from the imperial college of
london
yeah i think he vetted it and then
brought it on to the show and he told
poppy and all his friends about it i
mean say hey poppy
here's the problem ask the question you
go from the next part right okay kids
are gonna get it okay so if kids can
spread it
oh well first of all you're five months
behind on understanding that
people can spread the disease all right
fine okay
so so then what is that the end of the
okay kids can spread it so
we should never go back to school right
because kids can spread oh wow
there's also this new thing it's called
the flu yeah kids can also know if
you've ever heard them right
kids can die from that right i mean and
so and so that's where you like you
you get through the arguments you just
get to a certain point and then they're
like
and if you say anything bad you're a
terrible person you want to kill grandma
no what is the actual reality okay if
you are living at home
with your grandparents right maybe you
need to figure out a way to isolate
or maybe you have unless your
grandmother well then then maybe
yeah maybe that's a different
consideration ah grandma look at this
wet socks oh smell them get a good
inhale
wet socks i think that's probably the
most i'm not a doctor i would imagine it
would be an effective spread of bacteria
that's true dr mullet i'm going back to
the to the after the shower
my socks were sweating afterwards it's a
traumatic experience no this is true
there really are only two options at
this point okay and this is based on the
data and this is based on the opinions
of everyone at cnn and everyone on the
left and including dr fauci
the only point of view that you can have
is this is a virus right now
disease that will be among us and we
have to learn how to deal with it and
move forward
or shut everything down forever because
a temporary shutdown
isn't going to stop once you open back
up
it's still there it's not entirely gone
you look at sweden
they're mostly past at this point who
knows they could have another blip
seemed that they may have reached some
kind of immunity we don't know we
thought herd immunity would be 70
seems it may be lower for this virus
right now it's a novel virus we don't
know a whole lot about it but we do
know the irreparable damage that we've
done to the economy so why are we not
talking about this a bunch
because what is there left to say okay
open up and let people live their lives
let people make a living or
shut down forever i don't think you're a
nazi if you believe either i just think
that you're misinformed on the data and
you should probably shave your neck
hairs
yeah and there is there is no standard
yeah so it's like if if the standard is
nobody else is getting it there are zero
cases there are zero deaths is that
is that when school can start back up
when life can start back up yeah
they don't it's not working or when
public school teachers stop being lazy
pricks while claiming to be heroes
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so tired of this
the new york teachers unions are
dragging out
caskets they're dragging out caskets
like they're the undertaker in a coffin
match in the mid-1990s
this is ridiculous they're going out
there so we don't want to go back in
unsafe conditions and die
three months off isn't enough yet yeah
listen okay how about this
we're all in this together are you guys
taking a pay cut are teachers going to
not be paid
because this is something if we're going
to play identity politics we're going to
separate one by race gender okay we'll
gender sex have to separate the two now
even apparently it means the same thing
on a government id
they screwed that one up but if we're
going to separate everyone that way
there is a group of people here who are
more harmed
than other groups and that is business
owners that is people
who don't receive a paycheck as an
employee that is independent contractors
teachers aren't affected by that most
union members aren't affected by that
most employees aren't affected by that
so if we're all in this together and we
see all of these signs well
no does it affect everybody equally just
like the virus itself does it affect
children the same way it affects grandma
no
that's statistically verifiably false
does this pandemic shutting down of
businesses
affect everyone equally what are you
giving up public school teachers yeah
yeah and a lot of my sanity because my
students are my life well then go back
to them
now i'm confused
peanuts most of the time if people are
losing their jobs they're also losing
their health plans
right they're losing their only means of
actually paying for any kind of
treatment so
they're actually so people are worse off
with no jobs and the coronavirus
yeah i can hear leftists right now go
see you just made an argument for
socialized healthcare no you
dick we're talking about people being
allowed to
live their lives and be autonomous at
this point so the solution right
it's a total shutdown people lost their
healthcare plan let's give people more
healthcare plans let's give them
universal basic income teachers
don't want to go back let's give them an
extra stipend because three months off
isn't enough with an average salary of
70 something thousand dollars a year
plus
benny's this is it's just more money
more money more money more money we
spent trillions of dollars we don't have
the money and we're going to have less
money because people aren't going to be
able to pay taxes
so that's why we don't talk about it
anymore you know and you know what you
never hear about
are the number of teachers you have to
really dig or you have to go actually
talk to individuals which is hard right
now under the restrictions
when you talk to teachers who go look i
look i've always
know everyone knows that it's a petri
dish like you know dealing with students
certainly there's more of a risk and
certain teachers may have a particular
problem if they
live with someone or if they themselves
are particularly susceptible because
they have a pre-existing condition
right those are case-by-case basis and
these teachers are going
yeah i absolutely want to go back to
work and you know what a lot of them say
the reason why they want to do it
these teachers who are not getting a
voice right now is because they want
their students to learn
because they know that the socialization
they know that the in-person teaching
is what's needed and they know that how
is our mom and dad going to go back to
work yeah
listen if it's about the children okay
if it's about the children if it really
is
and i'm not saying that no teachers of
course going because they want a surface
shield of course plenty of them do but
not everyone
and i would be willing to bet not the
teachers who are out there dragging
coffins
down fifth avenue and aren't supporting
robust homeschooling system if it's
about the children
say okay shut down and let's help
support parents so that they can
homeschool their children
and then let's find what no instead of
just going i don't want to go back i
don't want to work and then i play all
day i don't give a [ __ ] okay
this is your job you have to go back to
your job and if you're doing it for the
children then right now
do it for the children if not don't
consider yourself a frontline hero we
had people getting into the trenches in
d-day and you won't go back to teach
children right now at a point where
again we're talking about a zero point
three percent death rate which
if i said this only a few months ago
banned banned because i would be saying
a death rate that is now
accurate but dr sanjay gupta was citing
the imperial college study which he's a
doctor this is the thing trust the
experts
all right well i don't know who's an
expert ah a doctor
dr mullet he seems like an expert oh
he's saying that uh he's setting that
study two million people dead
seems to check out i understand that
there are people who are more
knowledgeable and you need to trust
experts but at what point do you say
okay
all of the experts who we trusted got
these predictions verifiably wrong
and the crazy militiamen hooligans who
said it would be more comparable to the
flu
than the four three to seven percent
death rate
they were right so at a certain point
when experts
cease to give expert advice they cease
to be valuable
dr fauci aids when you look back at that
and how many people are going to get
that and that pandemic not saying aids
didn't exist
just like i'm not saying that
coronavirus doesn't exist the aids
epidemic as it would affect all
demographics
was absolutely a hoax was it oprah
winfrey said one in three heterosexual
couples
one in five let's say one in ten let's
say more than
zero percent would have been an
exaggeration winfrey
and i use win free because i'm not going
to use your first name because you put
that stupid little o on all your
magazines and guess who's going to be on
the cover this month
it's going to be oprah that's exciting i
gotta get that
oh my gosh but what pose though gotta
find her what is the pose if only i
could understand her plight
okay speaking of plight let's go to the
uh let's buy biracial i always have to
check my hands sure
just like joe biden had to check his
notes you found this what he was
announcing i think we have an overlay
announced
senator kamala harris for vice president
he had to have a script and a giant
picture of her face
the only thing missing is a giant yellow
bring that back up it's a giant yellow
arrow
it says don't say tulsi there's so much
going on in that picture you know you
have
i can't quite make out he's holding the
phone upside down he's
is he talking to her on the phone and
zoom i'm not exactly sure
he has a troll even if you look at the
little comic he has on his desk
i don't know if we have this i think i
sent it earlier a zoomed in
uh example of it uh but whether or not
you can see it it's a hangar the
horrible
okay and it's him saying yelling at the
heavens why me
and then this voice comes back and says
why not you right and so i
i really feel like that's a cry for help
like it's like
why me please not is that subtle he's
like i don't know what to do
i can't really say that i have a problem
because i can't speak right
right i'll just let hegar the horrible
save and because because of all the
facelifts he can't blink more so he's
just like right me
i can't do it ah poor guy that's
unfortunate it's kind of like the plot
of memento
at this point almost you know he's just
trying to escape which by the way
there's a special feature on that dvd
memento
um all right so let's get some facts as
to why kamala harris is just the worst
vice presidential candidate
no no steven we're not going to talk
about the facts because all that matters
is that she is a poc
that's right that's all that's all we're
hearing that is a fact literally
identity identity merits
yes no absolutely well let's go through
the merits because here's the thing i
when we talk about common ground and i
don't believe that you need to find
common ground on a lie
i think that there's right and there's
wrong and very often it's found maybe
somewhere in the middle but sometimes
it's not found in the middle at all
however today we can find common ground
to use my half asian learner's terms on
this pos kamala harris
because um everyone should unilaterally
dislike her
i will give you a reason as to why the
left will despise her or at least they
should if they're being consistent right
now with these riots less peaceful
protests
and of course the right should not be
happy uh or i don't think we'll be very
happy so the new york times wrote that
she was a pragmatic moderate so that
would seem like oh okay
all right kamala hair she's a pragmatic
moderate and we'll get to her criminal
justice history
which is really to the right of rudy
giuliani and maybe that's what they were
doing to tip the scales but on
everything else what do we have here
uh obviously universal healthcare she
supported after birth abortion i know
you might think well that's actually
some
we're exaggerating sure no no it's not
just northam and blackface
it too is kamala harris sports
afterwards abortion uh the green new
deal she supported
keep in mind that was a five-page bill
with sweeping legislation and also uh
the justice for all people
uh against fracking of course and she
co-sponsored a bill to force schools to
let transgender
athletes compete in women's sports uh
she was actually ranked from gov track
the furthest left democrat candidate
that there
is wow so that's one thing they're going
to try and say that she's moderate which
will this is the beauty of the left
today they are stuck between a rock and
a
hard
place right if someone says well
actually she's pretty modded they go we
don't want it
so they were saying yesterday right
before joe biden announced that they
said if you do not bring in
a a pos candidate um then you are going
to lose
the the pos the poc
poc poc yikes
i wasn't sure what i said but i think
what you were getting to is what i meant
to say
yes no exactly what you did say we can
rewind the tape
um they said that he would lose the
ethnic vote the minority vote they
didn't just say black vote they said he
would lose the person of color vote keep
in mind that's what they were saying
about joe biden so if
a woman it wouldn't be enough then he
picked kamala harris and then when you
see the media go actually she's a
pragmatic moderate the left goes we
don't want moderate we want
radical change for reference tune into
the young turks at any single point in
their channel or john oliver
right and then the problem is now we
understand what she's actually about
uh everyone else in the country is going
to say we don't we don't want it
so there's no winning right now at this
point i'm just wondering if joe biden
will even make it to november speaking
of whom
let's actually kind of the only
highlights people forget this during the
debates
kamala harris we talked when we watched
those debates i said oh she must she
drank her milk tonight she came in ready
to fight
she only really went after tulsi gabbard
a little bit but it didn't work
but one night she came out and went
after joe biden hard
so the vice presidential candidate let's
see her thoughts
on the guy at the top of the ticket but
i also
believe and it's personal and it was
actually very it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
what am i going to do and he's like how
sad should i look but
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me it was me i
leave him and i
i just double crossed them being able to
tell their story and having the courage
to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself i wouldn't tell him what to
do
well you might want to think about
trying
last point you might want to stick your
oar in there sweetheart
uh just pull one from the jamaican
plantation where your ancestors own
slaves we'll get to that in a second oh
yeah they tried to robot
like oh son of a [ __ ] it's the harrises
go go
jump in this lid um
so basically she thinks that this
there's a difference between uh
just saying i don't agree with this
person's policies and now running on the
ticket with someone who you've basically
said i believe the women who've accused
him of sexual assault
and he supported segregation this is my
guy yeah
it's like you know what uh i'm gonna
build a ticket with a rapist jim crow
that's my god by her own words
how how does she do this yeah at least
donald trump had the foresight at this
point even though he needed to kind of
unify the party was just him and ted
cruz left you know that was an option
for vice president
right you know i think it might be a
sore spot
that i said his dad killed jfk and
called his wife a pig
let's put him in a cabinet position and
i'll pick someone else i don't want the
friction
what'd you say his dad killed jfk i
didn't say this one people told me
there's no coming back from that
so now we have kamala harris and joe
biden what is that room going to be like
i don't think it's a problem
you really don't no i really don't
because biden doesn't remember any of it
they literally were like no no no no no
no that was a that was
kenny harris totally well good enough
for me
yeah he probably didn't even say that he
just went back to playing angry birds
listen we don't have time for this
because we got to make sure we that we
we win the caucus in iowa
oh
i think he's that far off that's the
thing like you go back to dan quayle and
george w bush you know like he choked on
a pretzel which was hilarious
that can happen to the best of us not
forgetting where you are and naming
naming trips that you made people you
never met in places that don't even
exist
it really is a creative guy good stories
though and i have a theory on that yeah
he's a he's a he tells his tall tales
yeah
i think he's a story so i'm going to get
to in a second i want to see anyone else
who agrees but first uh do hit the
notification bell if you're on youtube
because the subscriptions don't mean a
whole lot anymore and you
find out exactly when the stream is
which is of course monday through
thursday
every morning and uh we'll be doing the
live streams as we have democratic
convention town halls
not debate so it'll likely be anderson
cooper talking with a bunch of people
who grew up from a school shooting from
six years ago and they'll just somehow
tell it into presidency but
we'll be here to stream it anyway down
with the nra
that's the quality of programming you
can expect here um
here's another fast fact uh well it's
not really a fast fact it's just
it's just a fact uh she is the
descendant of slave owners kamala harris
now here's the thing
that's awkward it is awesome now i'm
asking red this morning i said can we
verify this
and i went to snopes and snopes you know
they
really want to say false though yeah and
they said
unverified well do you think they would
apply that same standard to someone else
if it was
let's say donald trump's father wrote in
2018 an op-ed
bragging that he was a slave owner i
have a quote right here my roots go back
within my lifetime to my paternal
grandmother miss christie
christina brown descendant of hamilton
brown who is on record as plantation and
slave
owner and founder of brownstown
that's almost as bad as white settlement
yes which is an actual city
uh he was out there bragging about it
the dad about slavery so
can we verify it not exactly but we know
that kamala harris hasn't denied it
uh and even snopes is like your guess is
as good as mine well i don't know is
your guess as good as her dad's
i'm willing to bet he did a 23 in me
ancestry.com
so he's proud he's proud of him
think about this for a second when they
accuse people of being tone deaf because
you're white
man a black man from jamaica wow
bragging about a town named after his
slave owner in a plantation
i mean you just think you just think he
like someone might have told
did he have anyone proofread this like
ah you know what hey uh you know what mr
uh
you might wanna i've highlighted some
portions in red
that's the best part about the
subservience
yeah i worked so hard on that that's
what we want
also the by i did the tanqueray
commercial that's that let's just not do
that because they no longer want to be
associated with us
so um here is something that is
important to me while we look at
everything through the lens of identity
politics
um kamala harris obviously she's a
wealthy person
she was ray she jamaica right uh
slave owner that's the ancestry so are
we going to argue that kamala harris
coming here to the united states
uh has faced the same kind of
discrimination
or or systemic racism that
african-americans are claiming as an
experience today and here's also the
problem with that let's take it a step
further because they say you have white
privilege you have well
really asian privileged nature that's
the thing because of a harvard and brown
interface it's just because we're better
yeah that is tremendous it's genetics
everyone gets uncomfortable when you say
genetics and you talk about asians are
better but they thought they are they do
better
right i mean they're taking over a
cultural bunch of the economy there's
like 19 billion of them
um i don't know why but your people are
fertile bill
you look at them wrong they get pregnant
so you want to say
that a lady who came from jamaica the
descendant of
slave owners has it worse off than let's
say someone from west virginia
who is not the descendant of slave
owners who was raised in poverty you
know what let's use
i'll use myself as a very specific
example because we assume that all white
americans
are uh the beneficiaries of slavery
right in to some degree or another and
that black people today
today in 2020 are somehow still feeling
those
systemic effects and that may be true in
some scenarios in my case
i was raised in montreal canada so on my
dad's lineage i don't know exactly if
there were any slave owners don't think
there were because we go all the way
back on my dad's side to french people
jacquardi who discovered canada on my
mom's side
absolutely not so i was raised in french
canada
as an english-speaking canadian look up
the language police and the language
laws in quebec i couldn't open up a
diner steven's apostrophe diner because
i began the laws because written in
english i had to go to all french
schools into the fourth grade they
thought i might be [ __ ]
turns out after when they switched me
over to an english school i was still
[ __ ] but the point remains
but you were with your people i was well
let's be careful especially with bridge
genetics and people talk about french
canadians
um english speakers so i was raised in a
family where my parents shopped at
goodwill salvation army none of us
benefited from slavery in any way and i
was in
a province in a country this is a
problem with multiculturalism where
there was
known systemic legal discrimination
against
people who were english speakers
regardless
as to whether they were born in quebec
or not you could be born in quebec your
parents could be english and born in
quebec yet you still faced systemic
discrimination then i moved to the
united states lived in 82 datsun
and finally we have this show here and
you know what i wouldn't say dreams come
true but
good enough yeah and you're still
retiring
yeah exactly yeah you know i'm on the
spectrum and so i want to be an
inspiration to people out there who need
a weighted blanket in thunderstorms look
this could all be yours so compare my
upbringing
with kamala harris and you want to say
that i need to check
my white privilege she's you're talking
about direct descendants of slavery and
they brag about it this is the problem
that happens and this is why you're
going to see more racism in the united
states and i'm really scared
about it i really am genuinely
frightened that you're going to see a
lot of young americans
in a similar scenario people who have
not seen a leg up who have who have been
told that they need to be
guilted that they need to be silent sit
down shut up and listen then they're
brow beaten and then someone like kamala
harris comes in and talks about how hard
she has it when it
there is verifiable proof that she
benefited from slavery
and kind of like the lolo jones kamala
harris could use it both ways
dye her hair blonde you're none the wise
are you doing indonesian
i don't know anyone see can we bring
that lolo jones at the olympics she was
like the biracial athlete then i just
watched a recent documentary
she was like hair brown and people like
oh i guess she's biracial now she there
you go there's lolo jones olympics now
let's look at lolo jones
today i don't know if we can find a
picture of a little jones today she
looks like she's picking up a pumpkin
spice latte and my point is
that's that's all right oh yeah totally
different person
good for her play both sides of that
coin kamala harris could do the same
thing i'm gonna use it
all right here's another issue um as a
prosecutor we're talking about black
lives matter the riots the violent riots
uh she kept inmates jailed for longer
to use them as cheap labor she supported
the death penalty which may surprise
people
and uh she incarcerated over 1500 people
for uh marijuana offenses so if we're
talking about moving the needle forward
for the potheads who just want to get
blitzed
she too is not your candidate can you
guys explain to this
uh this to people who may not be up on
the the nerdiness of the the prison
sentences
yeah i mean i think that the basic
scenario there was that
non-violent offenders were supposed to
be eligible for parole after serving
half their sentence right because
if you've got crowded prisons etc and
she wanted to keep them in to use for
cheap labor so essentially
another form of another form of slavery
right
yeah you might say yeah she's still
she's continuing the tradition she owes
two groups of people
i mean what's interesting about that is
that traditionally
you're going to see at least even with
trump you've seen a lot of attacks
about him being the law and order
president and right kind of
you know doing not not that actually
what's funny is even he doesn't do that
right
right right you know he's not well he
did the uh was it the uh um um what was
your name
uh alice marie johnson yeah yeah and
then his uh his first step
act was actually one of the first steps
towards changing the laws
on harsh sentences for non-violent
offenders right but at that time you
know if the laws were the laws the
judges need to do what they need to do
the only one who really had a lot of
discretion certainly judges had some
with regards to
evidence or you know sentencing but it
came down to the prosecutors it came
down
right to the district attorney for the
city of san francisco and what they were
doing and how they decided
to not only bring cases but what
sentences they were asking for
and what they were doing on the back end
when it came time for before parole
you cannot lay this at the feet at
anyone other than kamala harris
and i don't know maybe maybe they just
thought hey you know
we do actually have to show that we're
tough i mean certainly not you know push
up punch out mcgee over here with biden
you know but you gotta you gotta
actually have someone who's talking
about it but but the problem is i don't
think they
realize that a lot of folks really don't
want that it's clouded their message i
don't know how that flew in san
francisco
how she basically extended prisoner
sentences to use it as cheap labor
and also put in non-violent pot users
how did that happen at all did she just
like
was it just because she was dating
willie brown did she just sort of slide
in under the radar
what happened there who was she banging
to make non-violent drug offenders
end up in prison in san francisco you
could smoke a joint
at the in the foyer of the police
precinct in san francisco
and not i mean not even no one would bat
an eye
now granted you'd have the little hole
in your mask in some kind of a suction
so it creates some kind of a positive
pressure environment but the point
remains
smoke your weed in san francisco and
[ __ ] on the lawns
and yeah has anyone heard i haven't seen
him i've been trying to look around but
like her explanation
for she said she didn't know that was
her explanation basically she didn't
know with that one yeah she still with
that one yeah
i had no idea i had no idea just like
i had no idea that i owe reparations to
the guy who was locked up for a baggie
of weed
as well as the ambassador for red stripe
i didn't know that i had harmed
these many people uh even though it was
written about
national op-eds from my dad hey by the
way dad if you're listening
shut up please stop talking you know
i think i think you know what we should
just go we should go on a track record
question
right and uh if you don't know what's
going on you know for keeping people in
prison
in your small one city legal department
uh what we should definitely do is just
let you be in charge of the country yeah
exactly
yeah who would have ever thought that
the biracial black asian american pos
used bill's terms
kamala harris would be running right she
would be
she would be the lady who was locking up
non-violent black offenders and
extending their sentences running
against
donald trump who actually commuted
sentences
and introduced legislation that eases
penalties on non-violent drug offenders
despite the fact that he's a teetotaler
who would have thought that the most
moderate democrat
that we have according to the new york
times actually is to the right of attila
the hun when it comes to criminal
justice so of course
she's changed that now because she
listened to some tupac at a time before
he was born
yeah yeah because and you're a little
weak don't forget about that
i smoked a little weed really was it
rolled by a slave
no no that's called a prism that's a
prison
that is probably the most like the the
lack of self-awareness for her to talk
about
and clearly what was a lie but to even
lie about doing something
that is the same type of offense of the
people she was making
serve and beyond what they were normally
serving now again she didn't create the
laws
right so the laws were what the laws
were but she was the one that had the
power to make a difference
and so when you know even folks on the
left like you're going hey you know
let's let's think about this let's look
past
the color rainbow and figure out oh what
about the merits
right you know and i think i know i'm so
pissed about this and i'll
shut up after this point i don't want
you to shut up whenever you get a
candidate
of color from the right they never want
to talk about it
they're all it's just you know whether
it's bobby jindal when he was in
louisiana
or herman cain or any of the it's well
it goes from either tom right ben carson
it's either your uncle tom or
oh suddenly everyone's colorblind yeah
oh no no well
we we could look past just the race
let's talk about what he actually said
right and if we're going to by the way
if you're going to list accomplishments
because i do understand that there
obviously can be landmarks you know with
black people okay when you look at
robinson number 43 you're like okay the
first black person before that they were
watching
all white people do you have any idea
how boring it must have been to watch
sports when it was all white people
think about it all of a sudden the world
records were just shattered
it wasn't even close any sport that
involved
fast twitch muscle fibers it was like i
don't know we thought babe ruth was the
guy
have you seen what happened that guy was
spitting out beach nut and then uh going
out there and hitting homers and he
wouldn't even be able to hit a strike
so anyway that's the point there are
landmarks i understand it the first
black president
i would agree and i even thought when
that happened the one good thing that
maybe come from barack obama you know
socialism notwithstanding
is uh okay first black president maybe
we'll have some healing so i think
there's some validity to say
the first black president happened right
the exact opposite happened
it was under barack obama that we ended
up with black lives matter and more
racial divide than ever before and
that's what actually caused donald trump
to ascend to office but you're still
trying the same playbook
hope you like 2020 and what
what is remarkable to me is everything
on cnn or the radio npr this morning
marking history the first person of
color
uh to be nominated as a female vice
presidential can no sorry the first
female of color nominated for vice
president we had a black
president we had a black president okay
a half black
vp by the way we've already had female
vps nominated we had a female nominated
for the presidency
half black female nominee okay you're
going to put that up
as though it's more history-making than
the black guy and by the way not kind of
black we're not playing for the b
team he wasn't a bench warmer you're
talking about the guy who was raised in
detroit to a single mother household
tried to stab her but hit her belt
buckle
and was the first man to separate
conjoined twins
at the brain and you can
you can shimmy black in there the first
black man to
separate conjoined twins at the brain we
just skimmed
him because she has a vagina and a
little more melanin
which to quote nick cannon gives her a
soul i don't know if you know this
all of us end up in never-ending
purgatory unless we're black according
to nick cannon my point is if we're
going to talk about historical landmarks
it does need to be applied
equally and yes herman cain of course
condoleezza rice
colin powell but to me dr ben carson is
really the perfect example of course
officer david dorn when we talk about
him he's not the first but i think
he's a great example of what people
should look to during these times we
talk about examples for people and if
we're going to be looking at everyone
through the prism of race which is what
we're doing with kamala harris we're
seeing this right now it's a woman it's
vagina and race it's vagina
and racial genetics it's vagina and
ethnic makeup that's all that matters
right now in the vice presidential
pick she didn't make it far in the
primaries yeah
it's not like he picked the most capable
here she she proved verifiably that no
one
liked her yeah but but as soon as you
look past the woman of color thing you
have to start finding all the horrible
horrible things about it
they don't want you to see past no
exactly the man behind the curtain
wizard of oz
in her case it would just be a slave
like i work harder
i'll make faster i sorry
free me that's the day they mutter to
themselves no free me
for you that's a whole difference it's a
rivalry
god i cannot believe that she her dad
bragged about owning slaves and snopes
i don't know this one's up in the air i
don't know did you
ask him snopes did you make a phone call
for crying i should have him on speed
dial okay here's another one we're
talking about criminal justice
it's just the attitude that she has in
case you're thinking well this could be
taken out of context maybe she actually
really is about criminal justice reform
and about being more lenient about being
more compassionate
here we have a clip thank you rich for
finding this where she laughed about
prosecuting the parents of children who
committed truancy violations meaning
they were skipping class so i decided
i was going to start prosecuting parents
for truancy
she's so happy with herself
and frankly my staff went bananas they
were very concerned
we sent it out because it's a horrible
idea a friend of mine actually she went
with that
my wife got the letter she freaked out
she brought all the kids into the living
room held up the letter
said if you don't go to school kamala's
gonna put you and me
in jail yes we achieved a ten
intended effect yeah you did you scared
people with the gut with the arm of the
law that you had no authority to wield
you crazy wench and she's talking like
it's a pop-up book like
and we were saying that if the kids
didn't listen to their parents we were
gonna put them in the clink
as though it was on par with grand
larceny can someone get me more sherry
no you cry if you [ __ ] whoa didn't read
the room
so i had this wacky idea let's jail the
parents if i was that parent i'd be like
gather around kids look at this
we're not going to school anymore by the
way by the way this is something too
because
if we're talking about how laws
disproportionately affect people of
color
well let's talk about the idea that of
course disproportionately have a kid in
detroit for example
uh black child in detroit black teenager
in detroit has more chance of ending up
in prison than graduating high school
once they enter into school
and a big part of this is yeah they just
don't show up to class this happens as a
demographic black activists have talked
about this and how we need to fix this
they believe that fixing it is pouring
more money into schools
the point is this would
disproportionately affect black
parents kamala harris again i know you
have a blind spot because
slavery i get it so maybe you're not
necessarily super empathetic but even as
just a basic
white guy i'm like that's pretty screwed
up
think about that for a second the
parents and how how many
inadvertent ass beatings do you think
that this led to
from black mothers with kids who they
found skip in class
just because you know they didn't want
to get hit on a three-strike policy
don't you ever ever ever mom i just it
was
it was a science fair i didn't think i
needed to go kid makes a volcano toss it
together some vinegar and baking soda i
get it i want to go to mickey d's for a
coffee but
don't you ever kamala shh small ruins
everything that's the point here
so i think this it is inconsistent in a
way
right that she's doing this but i also
think it reveals something that
we all know deep down to be true that
leftists
when they are in power they don't mind
using that power to make people do stuff
right and so in that way it does make
perfect sense that you know
she also had the record of going after
uh david deladen remember in
the with planned parenthood and selling
the baby parts
and she went after him just through the
book at him
uh or her administration or whatever and
obviously
who knows how much money planned
parenthood is giving to her campaign
right and so
i think it's naive to think like that
once these people are in power
they won't use the police force or
whatever they have at that point
social workers to come cart you off and
make you do whatever they want to do
so i think it is it is inconsistent in a
way but it also just sort of shows their
hand that they're not really against
using
their political power she wanted to
charge parents for the same reason that
in new york they wanted to ban big gulps
they think that's a legitimate role of
government and listen i think yeah i
mean i don't even know has anyone seen a
truancy officer
i haven't seen a truancy officer since
the untouchables are those still things
i don't know i mean probably somewhere i
mean but maybe schools have them you
know and or
you know certainly there's officers that
may be like their job at the lowest
lowest
you didn't even get traffic duty right
right can we get a car you got to walk
around and find kids behind the 7-eleven
it feels like a very
mayberry thing to be checking up on like
right right did you go to school
absolutely which by the way i mean yeah
go ahead no i was gonna say i mean that
is the question though is
is this indicative of how she intends to
use her power when given a power when
given a little bit of power
she chooses to create her own definition
of what can be punished
she decides to start inflicting that
punishment
on parents who would i i think it's
pretty hard to make your kid go to
school when you're in jail
right or you're in court or you're
having to work extra shifts because you
have to pay for the fine that you got
from
laffy laffy taffy you know freaking
kamala
i think he was looking for himself and
that was like whatever i say is gonna
get me in trouble
right now yeah yeah could you see me
pulling that yeah okay snappy bro
payday oh henry snickers [ __ ]
snark doodles mars bar
vp p.o.s you got me thinking mayberry
that's why but but then
but then the idea the idea of extending
the
the non-violent offenders and how
they're doing for you know marijuana
charges
again that is the idea of okay now she's
in power let's multiply that
by a thousand fold and what are the
types of policies that she will
put on individuals when she's allowed to
and again based on her own warped view
of what's right or wrong and that view
was shaped by a family that owns slaves
in jamaica
but here's one thing i will say we've
this is something that you may have seen
a while uh ago
we're just gonna have to scrap the
second story today because we'll have
andorra on a little bit but first to
introduce
we don't have these problems i recognize
this as uh young white
truancy um of course people talk about
the police statistics
uh and uh for those who don't know um we
hope that you enjoy this installment
accurate to reality of white privilege
boys
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
all right there now timmy i know you're
a teenager but if i've told you once
i've told you a thousand times
you can't park your vehicle faced into
oncoming traffic come on let's move
well gee officer i'm sure sorry
can i just go back to my car now i want
you to follow my instructions either get
down on the ground or follow me away
from the vehicle but officer
can i just get my pcp now well
you know usually i'd say no but you can
make it quick come on get on out of here
you white rascal oh boy
i'm gonna freebase oh those boys
what tickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of
adventures of the white privilege boys
retired st louis police captain david
dorn
doran was shot and killed by a looter
earlier this week in north st louis
this was a great cop great cops do exist
and this is one of black lives have to
matter to us first
so until then we're gonna keep on having
these instances
of stupid
killings and stuff like that my uncle
didn't deserve to die like that
all right we are back uh of course uh
for people who want to go live shop.com
and you can purchase this shirt uh
i want to let you guys know though this
shirt is actually uh this is the beta
form this is not the real shirt which is
an inkjet on blue so you will get a
better shirt
you'll get the alpha form it is a real
shirt this is a real shirt
that's not an illusion contrast with my
with my pants which are today
non-existent
i couldn't find my pajama pants but a
robe is good enough
uh and we'll be having on here in a
couple of moments we're trying to
connect with um
miss ann dorn of course uh uh she is the
wife
of the uh officer david doran i'm trying
do you say
widow i don't i don't know the the term
to use that is non-offensive here but
obviously we say so in the greatest
respects and
listen one of those things we have a
platform where we can
bring attention um to these kinds of
stories and i will say this when we were
on air uh with the david dorn store for
people who don't remember
and uh by the way we'll be reading some
of your chat behind the paywall in a
little bit here
um it was the hardest thing i think i
had to watch live yeah that was rough
it was really tough to watch uh and the
reason i think it was so tough to watch
when people try and say well you don't
have
uh the same kind of empathy for example
george floyd we were all really upset
about george floyd
everyone here was but we all knew that
we weren't seeing the full context of
that tape
you see a beginning middle and end with
the david doran tape you know i mean
there's a lot of
there was a lot that came out right away
with that story and i think the reason
it was so gut-wrenching too was because
no one in the media was really talking
about it this was a guy
who really was a pillar of the community
where he served as an officer for many
years
he was an example that should have and
could have been followed and he
was killed his life was taken doing
exactly what it was that he had done his
whole life to try and improve the lives
of those in the black community he was
never a net drain
he was never a net burden he was always
a net positive and this is someone we
could look to if we're talking about
finding common ground and instead
um very little coverage yeah very little
it pisses you off
yeah it really makes you mad that they
talk about these other people but not it
was a hero
king too it changed my mind who was just
done yesterday and we'll have more by
the way with antifa i believe next
tuesday in the change of mind and how
that escalated
um where he said well i only have so
much time in the day yeah that was his
answer i only have so much time in the
day well he didn't know about him
didn't really know about him so was that
some kind of a black cop as far as he
knew this was carl winslow
he had who by the way i also support i
back the blue
heroes both real and fictional yeah not
all heroes have a below
48 inch waist that's true with carl
winslow um
i don't know do we have a miss dorne are
we looking to to get her here
it doesn't look like we do we're still
trying to connect we have audio
videos oh we have audio but it's not
letting us do video yeah
it's not letting her do video but she
can hear me right now and uh can we do
we have like a lower third we can bring
up so people can
if we can't get her to do video good
enough i think that uh her voice being
heard
is important enough uh as is miss uh ann
dorn are you there can you hear me
just make sure miss and and dorne are
you there can you hear me
oh i don't believe you can she hear you
we're not seeing any indication there
no she can hear us but we can't hear her
all right
let's grab bill and red let's bring him
back in here because uh right now i
don't
i don't want to go to story number two
uh and then go back to uh
anne dorne sure but um i'm really
looking forward to having her on so i do
want to have her on a little bit just
let me know when we have the connection
i don't know what's going on with this
damn apple tv bill reg get back in here
somebody help me
so um here's another story that we have
before we bring on dorian just let me
know when we do it yeah we'll deal with
it
um there was another uh
murder that happened that you may not
have heard of this one makes me mad yeah
this one is
this one is a piss off since everything
is being seen through the prism of race
and through the prism of guilt and
vilification with officers out there and
the idea of course that they're out
hunting young black males and that
there are no ramifications for people uh
uh
there are no ramifications for white
people right who kill
black people that's what we're often
hearing right now particularly officers
um we do know and we'll talk about this
a little bit more obviously
the interracial crime is something that
needs to be discussed and it needs to be
discussed honestly
and accurately and that means looking at
the data and the data is pretty clear
that black americans right now are 10
times more likely to commit violence
against white americans than vice versa
you just don't know the names of those
victims
well here's another one that you may be
surprised to learn about and
there's nothing graphic here so i don't
need to warn you but um i believe his
name was was it
canon hidden hint how was the last name
says it in the video a five-year-old in
north carolina
who was shot riding his bike in his
front yard
and then his neighbor darius essence
shot this kid in the head i believe we
have a clip from the local news
affiliate
five-year-old cannon hinnon loved to
ride his bike and loved
animals his mother tells us he was
always smiling
and loved his family now the family is
preparing for his funeral
police say 25 year old darius sessoms
a neighbor shot the child and it was not
an accident
the reason is still unclear police
believe the suspect took off in this
black toyota corolla without a front
bumper
cannon's family was too distraught to
talk on camera
they just hope the killer is brought to
justice
so i want to be clear the motive from
the the kill right now is still not
necessarily
entirely clear there's a gofundme that
was started by uh i believe a family
member
have we confirmed that i think it is
confirmed uh who says that the boy did
ride into this man's yard and and
not really they said that he came over
the killer
came over to their house the day before
so they knew each other and it was like
now did he come over to complain about
the kid riding his bicycle i don't know
they said for dinner they said dinner
yeah for dinner yeah
so do we have any was just a case of
mistaken identity where he thought it
was someone else riding a bicycle in his
lawn who he had the right to shoot and
by the way i'm all for property rights
and i understand that sometimes mistakes
are made if there's a threat
um but this is a scenario where again we
have to wait for some context a
five-year-old on a bicycle
i don't know how you make that mistake i
can't think of a context where that
makes sense
no i can't think of a context where it
makes sense and the police right now
haven't thought of a context where that
makes sense because at this point i
believe that actually um there are
charges that have been brought you were
the one who found the story
reg right yeah no i just you know saw it
floating around twitter and
you just think the bizarre thing about
it is
it's not being reported on by any major
outlets right um
you know msnbc abc's i think we actually
have an overlay yeah for people to see
we have msnbc cnn nbc washington post
abc
when this story had happened and not a
single one covered it
yeah we went through and just i checked
them this morning just to to see if
anyone had covered it and just
nothing right uh so i mean you just
think
if the the races were reversed the
headline you know
five-year-old black boy rides riding his
bike playing with his sisters and his
white neighbor comes out and shoots him
in the head
it would be all we would hear about for
months right
and you there would be no wait for a
context or anything right no exactly
even if charges were brought by the way
that's why it doesn't really matter
because there were charges brought
against officer chauvin pretty damn
quickly
and then they upped the charges and it
still wasn't enough and in this case
we're just seeing it reversed and it
really is remarkable that you're not
seeing this story anywhere i'm not
saying it's indicative
of all crime going on in this country
but when you look at this and okay the
media is not covering this let me ask
you have you ever heard the media when
they talk about
officers right police officers and
police brutality
have they ever told you that you're
actually more likely to be shot by a cop
if you're white have they ever told you
that there's a higher percentage of
police officers who are minority than
the general population
have they ever told you that more likely
to use force against a minority
perpetrator
is a minority officer have they ever
told you that there's a 10 times
the rate of black on white crime versus
white on black crime have they ever told
you that the number one cause of death
for young black men under the age of 44
is homicide have they ever told you that
an officer is 18 times more likely to be
shot by a young black male than vice
versa
now you can look at this through the
prism of race and melanin as someone
like nick cannon does which basically is
just a form of genetic supremacy or you
can look at this and say
there is something very broken right now
in our culture
with broken people black and white now
it is black and white broke people are
broken but people are broken
in different ways in different
communities and we've talked about that
with a 70
fatherless household right now in black
american uh households
that's a real problem and it manifests
itself
in ways that that unfortunately there
are real consequences
and we're not focusing on the real
consequences because people are shouting
the loudest how do we know that they're
shouting a lot of us because they're
robbing
tesla dealerships and burning down
police precincts it doesn't mean that
what they are saying
is right now it doesn't mean that this
story is something
that should inspire you to go out and
only care about this story that's not
what i'm saying at all but what i am
saying is this is a story that wasn't
covered because of political expediency
from the media
and statistically you need to understand
that this is far more likely than
happening
when the roles are reversed but when the
roles are reversed that's all you hear
about
and that's why i think it's important
for every american out there to assume
that there is no
unbiased journalism to assume um
that you're getting you're getting a
spin and you have to do your due
diligence because
no one how does no one i mean this is
this is freaking catnip for
fear-mongering media
well yeah and i think that's the thing
that's so disturbing is you think
there's no argument that this
isn't newsworthy i mean i have not heard
any story like this in recent memory
of a child being shot in their front
yard you know in front of their siblings
uh but but you know and again we don't
know the motive the guy could be
schizophrenic he could have mental
problems or have some some some problem
that has nothing to do with the rest i
certainly don't think it's right i don't
think it's racially motivated yeah i
think it's a tragedy it's just
it's not covered equally but the but the
where the race comes in
is that there was conversations
apparently at these news outlets that
said don't cover this because of the
race
right right that's the only explanation
is that
there were some conversations had abc
msnbc cnn nbc
so on and so forth that there was for
some reason don't cover the story
because it doesn't fit and i think there
were similar conversations or certainly
it would seem that way if you run those
searches and those same major outlets
uh with uh our next guest in the story
of course officer david dornan go
letters with crowdershop.com and
purchase this shirt
all proceeds will go to the family
affected um i believe we have around
miss
and dorne can you hear me
well thank you so much for being here i
appreciate you making the time
um and what are you for miss mrs and
dorne miss dorne
and i you know it's one of the obvious
this is a sensitive subject and
and you're on under circumstances that i
wish were different uh and i get
intensely uncomfortable
i'm sorry i had an echo i couldn't hear
you very well that's okay it was just me
making uh nonsensical statements
i'll go with miss dorne mrs dorn um
listen for people who may not
know this story we were just talking
about the media what they cover what
they don't cover and um
for people who've watched this stream we
did show a portion of the video of your
your husband your late husband uh an
american hero
and it was one of the hardest things
that i ever had watched on air we
actually had to cut to someone else i
had to kind of gather myself but
unfortunately a lot of people out there
and we just found this out last week
by the black lives matter activists with
whom we spoke on the street in austin
they weren't familiar with this story at
all um could you
sort of brief people for those who
aren't in the know which unfortunately
is too many
um the night of june 2nd
my husband was helping a friend as he
always does
and he was answering an alarm call which
he's done numerous times
before without any problems um
and during that call he was shot by a
looter
unfortunately was killed yeah
and that's i mean that's that's the
short end of it uh i think people should
should know that you're your husband
uh officer david dorn he um was a part
of the saint louis pd can
for how many was it 30 something years
he spent 38 years with the st louis
metropolitan police department he
retired as a captain
right and you yourself as well if i'm
not mistaken you were you're a sergeant
i'm a sergeant yes okay 27 years 27
years so both police officers and
you let's we'll get into kind of the
explorers program which you did with
young people interested in in law
enforcement and i know i want to make
sure that people know
there is going to be um before we move
on a peace march uh
on august 29th in downtown st louis that
i believe you're a part of correct
correct yes okay yes correct 29th at
10am
and what what do you intend to
accomplish with this with this piece
march right now because obviously there
are plenty of marches or as people in
the media would say peaceful protest
going on across the country it almost
sounds like well why do we need
another peaceful march it's almost as
though there's a contrast with what's
actually going on right now
i'm trying to bring all walks of life
together
everyone on both sides of the debate the
good and the bad
the right and the wrong you know
everybody has their own opinions
but i want to start the conversation i
want to start the healing process
i've worked with kids i've worked with
you for 27 years
and i want us to reach out to them and i
want
to figure out how do we heal the
community how do we start we have to
start at home
first and figure out what's broken and
i want to figure out like i said i want
to figure out what's broken so we can
try and heal
yeah and try and bring some peace back
to the community
well i think some sorry i i know there
is a little bit of an echo so i
apologize if i interrupt i'm also
interrupting myself right now so
we're both the victim of my lab your
mouth um let me
ask you this because right now obviously
the narrative is that what is broken is
a
police force and that they are targeting
young black americans in record numbers
right now that's why we have the black
clouds matter protest that's what people
believe true or not
i think a lot of people aren't aware
that there's a higher percentage
of police officers who are minorities in
the general
population and unfortunately they often
get the worst
they get the brunt of it because
sometimes they're seen as traitors
or they're seen as uncle tom this has
happened a lot my dad was raised in
detroit he was there during the detroit
riots he had a friend who um
had a father who was a black officer he
had to go home and unmarked cars back
then
considering how it's almost there's they
are unsung heroes and
often black officers aren't given the
credit that they deserve
why would someone like your husband
david dorn go into
what inspired him to go into what is
unfortunately often a thankless
role
he just loved helping the community he's
always been a giving spirit he's always
been a godly man
um whatever he could do to help somebody
is
i guess is what led him in that
direction his father was a reserve
officer
um years and years ago
when very few blacks were even on the
department and allowed to be on the
department
so i think having his father as a
reserve officer really
inspired him to follow in his footsteps
well yeah and that's interesting that he
wanted to serve his community want to
help people
and he saw becoming a police officer as
a way to do that and i'd like to
continue on that
um andorn if you can hold for one second
right now we are going to uh cut this
feed on youtube because
for some reason they give us problems so
youtube you can take a hike we're going
to continue on mug club in just a second